Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and there are
just so many WTF moments in this week’s
Walking Dead, we need to get right in it.
A whole bunch of plots were tied up and there
was a major homage to a comic book moment.
Quick shout out for the giveaway this week.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I’m doing a weekly Walking Dead giveaway,
just to say thank you to you guys for being
so awesome.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
We have some major stuff to work out here,
so I’m going to do my Top 5 WTF moments,
then my review.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Here we go,
Number 5 - Lizzie’s New Friend Grizelda.
There was so much wrong about this, did anyone
else scream at their tv?
Her performance, the actress was a little
too much, but we got the message.
Lizzie is batshit crazy.
The best part was seeing Carol get that look
on her face like, I’m so going to end up
having to put Lizzie down.
And then the camera pans over to Tyreese looking
through the window and he’s got the ‘what
the fuuuu’ face.
It’s pretty clear even at this point that
Lizzie is going to be the biggest problem
in this episode.
Not Walkers, not finding food, not Mika toughening
up and not finding the others.
Number 4 - Lizzie feeds the Walker.
What the eff.
At least we finally got a definitive answer
about who was feeding the Walkers.
This was so disturbing.
Lizzie shall make you understand.
Based on the scenes in the teaser I knew that
she wasn’t going to get bitten this soon
in the episode, but the minute her hand reached
out I just wanted to slap her.
It seems like in her mind she’s seeing all
of them as they were and just can’t move
forward in her mind.
Developmentally she’s just stuck at the
point of the outbreak before everything went
to hell.
I did love how Mika just walked up to Lizzie
and the walker like it was no big deal.
You’d think if there was a walker nearby
you’d do everything you
Number 3 - Tyreese remembers Karen.
The irony of the scene was just beautiful
with Carol in the foreground and Tyreese just
going on and on about his Karen Nightmares.
Remember earlier in the episode where he’s
asleep on the chair jerking around.
He was probably having a Karen Nightmare right
then.
I really did expect Carol to come clean when
she goes to speak, but I’m glad she saved
it for later in the episode.
Did anyone else laugh a little bit when Tyreese
went to hug her and had the gun in his hand
as he wrapped it around Carol.
It’s like they were saying, murder is right
around the corner.
Which is why the next moment was so appropriate.
Number 2 - Lizzie kills Mika.
She’s full on Ben.
I was just about to change Judith too.
Everyone had been wondering if they girls
were going to take the place of Ben and Billy.
And it went down exactly the way it did in
the comics.
Here’s a shot of Ben right after killing
his brother.
The only difference is that Carl was involved
in the resolution and in the episode it’s
Carol.
After seeing Lizzie’s character progression
this season, and this episode, I don’t think
there’s any other way this could have gone
down.
Even if they had made it to Terminus together,
Lizzie still would have continued doing the
same things and because Mika was so attached
to her, she would have either been killed
by a Walker because of Lizzie or by Lizzie
herself.
So unless Lizzie turned first, Mika would
have died eventually no matter what.
Number 1 - Carol kills Lizzie.
Just look at the flowers and count 1.2.3.
Because I’d read the comic story I kept
expecting this to happen since the Mika killing
was exactly like the twin killing in the comics.
I think they made it a little more emotional
since Carol was like they’re surrogate Mother.
I had actually expected her to shoot Lizzie
on the spot when she got the gun out of her
hand.
I wasn’t a huge fan of the transition from
Mika to the house to Carol shooting Lizzie.
The pace just felt a little stop and go.
And I had hoped that Lizzie’s death would
have been a little more intense.
There was a lot they chose not to show us
in the episode.
They didn’t show Lizzie stabbing Mika and
they didn’t show the bullet hitting Lizzie’s
head.
Personally I think they shot it that way and
AMC made them take it out.
But you can comment on whether or not you
think they intended to show us the actual
deaths.
In the end, I’m glad she’s dead.
If you didn’t hate Lizzie before this episode,
then this was the last straw.
I have no idea where they would have gone
with her character had she lived and made
it to terminus.
Clearly she was going to kill Baby Judith,
after she confessed as much I wanted Carol
to shoot her so bad.
And my bonus WTF moment - Carol Confesses
To Tyreese.
I love how you can see murder on his face
as he’s just shaking the table with his
grip.
But he’s wrapping his brain around it and
forgives her.
Not to say that he’ll ever forget.
I love his quote though.
“It’s a part of you now.
Me too.”
It’s a big callback to Tyreese’s earlier
talk with Carol about the talking to them.
And Carol’s answer that they’re not haunting
them, just reminding them of what they have
to do.
And so they continue on to terminus.
I think we’re meant to take away that Tyreese
isn’t going to harm Carol, but they’re
never going to be pals they way they might
have been, had awful things not happened.
Tyreese wanted to stay at the cottage so bad.
How ironic that he said he wasn’t ready
to be around people when Carol then said Lizzie
can’t be around other people.
Let it not go unsaid though, the thing I was
most excited about in this episode was Baby
Judith NOT dying.
As awful as everything was, that made me happy.
But now it’s your turn, what was your biggest
WTF moment?
The deaths, or some of the craziness that
preceded them.
Each Lizzie moment throughout the episode
felt like it successively increase my stress
levels.
Overall I give the episode an A for having
the guts, so to speak, to kill of two major
characters in a way completely faithful to
the comics.
As an asterisk though, I give Lizzie’s performance
a C for acting.
I knew what the actress was trying to convey,
she’s like the Joffrey of the episode.
And the problem with that is that they’re
supposed to make you hate them, which they
do beautifully.
But when you hate a character, sometimes they’re
unbearable to watch.
Mika’s performance was a fresh breath of
sanity.
Mika get your gun.
I would have liked to see the deleted scene
that preceded her stabbing, maybe it will
be on the DVD.
But I don’t think even HBO would show a
child stabbing another child.
Even on Game of Thrones when Arya killed that
boy in season 1, they kind of cut away really
quickly.
I’ll say the child acting I did love in
the episode was when Mika was comforting Lizzie
the first time and they chant in unison.
It reminded me of the creepy twin girls from
The Shining.
Did anyone else get that vibe?
I loved Tyree’s performance in the episode.
I almost felt like he had the hardest job.
He had to convey all these emotions without
really doing anything.
His character is not a good communicator,
so a lot of his performance has to be physical.
And that last scene with Carol was beautifully
intense.
Let me know what you thought of the episode,
and are you happy Lizzie is dead.
Even if it meant Mika had to die too.
In related news, I’ll be posting my next
Q&A tomorrow night and announcing the latest
winner in my giveaway.
All you have to do is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video.
Right now click here for more of my predictions
for the season finale.
A few of them were already answered in this
episode, and click here for the Q&A video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!